What will happen?
The Joe Rogan experience,
another one people got really mad about this is this weirdly the one we got the
biggest reaction to.
Um,
and uh,
to the extent that I'm a little hesitant talking about it cause it will start to
show storm every time I do what means?
Uh,
no,
actually we have not done a whole one on vaccines.
Uh,
but we really should cause it's coming back.
I used to think that vaccines was like kind of done as a topic and like we've
gone through it is really,
it is really backing.
It is big.
Um,
but no,
we didn't want on Alpha males,
we had an episode about dating and we did one on how the idea of the Alpha male
doesn't exist in humans.
Like if you talk to any anthropologist,
any biologist,
and you're a sociologist,
right?
And be like,
are humans organized in a social relationship where there's Alphas and Betas?
The be like,
no,
what are you talking about?
This is an unscientific idea.
Right?
And we just did something laying that out in a,
in a,
in the context of like,
people who are,
oh,
my type is,
I like Alphas,
right?
Well,
there's no such thing actually,
you know,
humans are some,
your dominant,
some situations not in others.
Right.
Um,
it's an overly simplistic way of looking at human relationships.
And I thought there was a pretty simple,
straight forward thing.
I was like this just a bit of pseudoscience that you hear people tossing out and
people went ballistic on the Internet because people have sort of like built a
edifice of ideology in their minds about like,
there's Alphas,
they're spayed is I'm an alpha.
This is what now feels like,
this is what a Beta is like,
you know?
Um,
and uh,
and way the words.
Yeah.
Clearly.
Men who are more aggressive and athletic and dominant and more confident and s
and then men who are introverted and shy and more nervous and anxious and
there's a scale
in some,
in some situations,
you know,
situations and that's what we're talking about.
Right?
And socially,
well,
yeah,
but you're a social situation could change based on what situation you're in.
You know what I mean?
Like,
but,
uh,
like an athletic,
confident male is always going to be an athletic,
confident male and an introverted anxious male who has problems with social
anxiety is going to be the same.
That's that.
Personally,
I don't think so necessarily.
Um,
but uh,
so when we're talking about,
we're talking about Alphas,
right?
Um,
in animals,
what is that?
It's a social hierarchy,
right?
Um,
when you're done animals in,
take away that word,
I mean w but what people are using to describe when they're saying Alphas and
Betas,
they're saying like confident,
strong,
secure people and people that are anxious and not
so if you're,
so if you're trying to say,
hey,
like it's good to be confidence,
not so great to be anxious like that,
that's fine.
Right?
But when people talk about Alpha males and Beta males right there,
specifically bringing in the language of like evolution of biology,
of zoology,
of evolutionary psychology,
you know,
and they'll start saying stuff like,
well,
there's Alphas and there's Betas and women are hardwired to be attracted to the
Alpha,
you know,
because that's what it's like in nature.
Like there'll be using that language.
Right?
And so what we're pointing out is that's not scientific,
right?
It's not active.
But it is true that women are hardwired to be attracted to confident athletic
men.
I,
well,
I don't know if
I agree with that.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
you don't think that women look at like pro athletes and like big,
strong athletic men and you don't think they're drawn to that for evolutionary
reasons?
I know.
I don't actually,
I think that.
Okay.
Do you think that men are drawn to women with small waists and big hips and
large breasts for evolutionary reasons?
Uh,
you know,
I think that's an easy,
I think what that is,
is that's an easy intuition to come to if you're like looking at the way people
behave.
Right.
But one of the things about evolutionary psychology is it's the most common
mistake to look at the way that people do behave and say,
the reason what the hell we behave that way is because evolution says that's the
best way,
right?
That's their argument.
For instance,
I'll give you an exact,
that's the argument that was arguments like you like that were used for
instance,
to justify slavery.
Right?
That like,
oh,
because you know,
uh,
whites and blacks have this hierarchical relationship and American society.
That's the way it was intended.
That's how nature intended it to be.
Right?
But we can't,
we can't,
we can't make that leap.
The shapes of bodies,
men universally are attracted to a certain shape of bodies.
There's men that are attracted to different ones and doing it,
I don't think irreversibly attracted at the same barrier,
but that hourglass shape has been throughout time,
something that men are attracted to.
I think that hourglass shape,
there's something throughout our recent cultural memory that we tell each other
that men are attracted to.
Right?
That's when that's when we're,
that's what we're told from an early age to this,
that this is the sort of women that men are attracted to.
And so a lot of men ended up adopting that.
Right.
But I don't think that deep down that's how men naturally are,
you know?
Yeah.
I read this.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
That's so non intuitive because I'm all about things that are not intuitive.
Well,
where do you think it started?
Where do you think this,
this narrative of men being attracted to women with large breasts and a small
waist and a big ass,
where do you think that started?
Because this is like evolutionary biology is pretty much settled on the idea
that the reason why as a,
the large hips would indicate that the women would be easier to give birth.
Having large breasts and a large acid indicates that she has,
uh,
she's,
she's fertile and then she has ample fat storage in the right places if she's
going to be pregnant and carry children.
There's all these like evolutionary biology reasons why people are attracted to
certain things,
why women would be attracted to a tall,
muscular,
a handsome man,
good genetics,
very strong and confident can take care of her.
All these things are based on evolutionary biology.
So I don't understand why you think these are learned sort of cultural art.
So my,
my question,
my question is this is an assumption that we,
the public make about how evolutionary biology works,
right?
It's more of a thing that we sort of agree on.
Well we,
we as the,
like there's a,
there's an idea among the public that this is true.
I don't know if it's a scientific idea.
That's what you have.
I've had conversations with evolutionary biologists who explained the reason why
men are attracted to certain shapes and why women are attracted a certain
shapes.
This is,
this is of,
I mean this is science in a way.
I mean this is the reason why they're attracted to tall men that are muscular
and confident is because that is what's always saved you throughout history.
I mean co to only make sense doesn't it?
It.
Well,
just because it makes the point of our show,
right?
Is that just because something makes intuitive sense doesn't mean that it's
necessarily true.
Right?
But don't you think that in this case that this is a varied argument?
Like I don't think that's something that you can dismiss.
I don't,
I don't dismiss it,
but I don't assume the truth of it simply because that's what,
you know,
everybody agrees upon,
right?
Girls like what are you into?
And you say,
if you are you into tall,
muscular,
confident men who are also nice to do Jesus Christ,
that's going to be off the charts.
It's going to be like most of them.
I'm,
you know,
I'm really not sure that's the case.
Really.
You had like a survey of women and the men were equally kind and equally
intelligent and,
and friendly.
You don't think that more women will be sexually attracted to these tall,
handsome men with great bodies.
I mean,
look,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna say that like for first of all,
you're positing like a value judgment in it that the,
that the bodies are great,
right?
So like are women attracted to attractive bodies?
If that's the question then,
then I would say the courts more attracted to women's study.
Some fucking,
I'm talking about with the dad bod something.
Here's something that I was really influenced by Iran.
What I just said though,
that doesn't make sense to you that women would be attracted to someone who's
fit.
Look,
I mean it's a,
it's a hypothetical,
right?
Like I certainly athleticism,
right.
Is something that is attractive,
right?
Um,
that's something that many people find attractive,
right?
Not everybody finds that attractive.
Um,
and I don't think that we can necessarily reason backwards to like a specific
evolutionary relationship.
Right.
Um,
because the truth of what those evolutionary relationships are is like often a
lot more complicated than,
you know,
our,
our immediate intuition about it.
And what were you specifically pushing back against in that segment is like the
really sort of unscientific,
you know,
of Alpha and Beta.
Yeah,
exactly.
Where it's like,
you know,
you've got people,
just on internet forums,
like sort of doing amateur pseudoscience,
right?
Saying like,
this is how the relationships we had men and women are like designed
evolutionarily.
Um,
and we were just pointing out on a very,
very simple level,
like the Alpha and Beta social hierarchy theory,
right?
Um,
that like a humans are organized in a social hierarchy and Alphas are above
Betas,
not true.
Right?
Um,
even someone who is the person who you posited,
right?
The person who is a athletic and confidence,
The,
uh,
you know,
the high school football quarterback,
right?
Versus the high school football nerd,
right.
We'll take those two people and then put them in a different situation,
If those two people are like in gym class together,
right?
Of course,
the high school quarterback is like on the top of that social interaction,
right?
Um,
looking at the sort of,
you know,
classic Wolf Pack Model,
they're the one who's sort of running the show,
right.
In the other guys,
like hanging out in the bleachers,
talking to his friends,
right?
Or talking to nobody because he's a,
he's a Beta in that situation,
right?
If you then take that kid and then you,
you know,
send that kid to like nationals,
right?
Or whatever,
uh,
you know,
and that kid,
sorry,
I take the,
the quarterback character.
Um,
and you know,
he's suddenly like,
you know,
from the little podunk town,
right?
He's not from the big school.
Um,
he's like way down on the Totem Pole,
right?
That person is no longer going to be in that high social hierarchy.
Right?
Um,
and if you take that nerd and you put that,
you know,
take that kid and maybe he's the dungeon master of his,
dungeon and dragons group,
right?
Um,
uh,
that,
that kid is going to be the alpha in that situation,
right?
That's how humans work.
You know,
humans aren't organized in sort of like little pods that stay together for life,
and there's one person who's dominant the whole time.
Right?
And that's the simple point that we were making,
uh,
in that piece.
Right?
Um,
and people get upset.
Yeah.
People got upset because there are so many people who we talked about this later
on the show.
There's this idea called the backfire effect,
right?
Where when people are told something that they don't agree with,
um,
that when they,
when they,
someone has told somebody a fact,
when somebody has told the fact that contradicts like a really deeply held
belief,
it can often cause them to disbelieve it even when it's true.
Right.
In fact,
that fight back even harder.
Yeah.
One of the reasons that happens is because of an idea called identity protective
cognition.
It's,
um,
if the fact that is being debunked is literally part of your identity.
Like if something that you believe really,
really deeply,
it's incredibly hard for you to disbelieve it.
Right?
The classic example of this is like,
you know,
Sean Hannity,
Sean Hannity doesn't believe in climate change,
right?
Uh,
uh,
really?
Uh,
well,
you know what,
uh,
I actually don't know that specifically what Shawnee,
Sean had thinks about climate change.
Let's just say somebody who's made their whole career on climate change doesn't
exist,
right?
All their friends are in the anti climate change community,
Uh,
they met their wife at an anti climate change fundraiser.
You know what I mean?
They make their money,
they're at a new anti climate change book every year.
Right now,
climate change is real,
right?
There's no evidence I could present that person with that is going to make them
take the social risk of ending all their relationships changing their whole
life.
Right?
Uh,
because if they were to say,
okay,
you know what,
actually,
I'm convinced climate change is real,
they would lose all their friends.
Their wife would leave them,
they would lose their revenue stream.
They can't possibly come to that conclusion.
Right?
And so they fight back.
So super hard.
Right?
And so that's what ended up happening with that segment.
There's a whole group of people who have built their whole lives on the idea.
There's Alphas and Betas.
I'm an Alpha.
I'm not going to be a Beta.
Right?
Um,
and so,
and,
and maybe that Muslim positive to them,
you know,
maybe they had,
were in a bad place in their life and through this model of Alpha versus Beta,
they started working out or they started,
you know,
improving themselves a little bit.
Right?
Um,
and maybe they started acting a little bit more confidently and now they're in a
relationship.
Right?
All those things can be true with the idea of Alphas and Betas and humans not
being scientific.
Right.
But so when I tell them that they fight back really hard though.
No,
no,
no.
This is,
this is real.
This is real.
You know,
and so that video,
which again,
I had no idea that'd be controversial.
I got the most,
or youtube response videos,
get the most,
you know,
furious things.
And the weirdest thing was people started to say,
this is political.
Like,
why is Adam Ruins everything getting political?
I'm like,
I don't know what the hell they're talking about or this is,
I have no idea.
It's political.
Alphas and Betas are now political.
I mean,
that's what people were saying,
I guess.
Uh,
I guess,
you know,
for some people it's become that,
but because they've see it as part of like,
I don't know,
whatever argument they're in their head they're having about feminism or
something like that.
But to me,
I'm just like,
guys in dating right in life,
like this is not a real concept.
If you want to say I'm going to be confident tomorrow,
I'm not going to tell you,
that's not gonna help you out.
You know?
Um,
uh,
and you know,
I am a little bit reticent to make like a broad conclusion about evolutionary
psychology.
Right.
But I can tell you again,
go talk to any anthropologist,
any biologist and he,
you know,
a sociologist.
Is there such a thing as Alpha males in humans in the strictest scientific sense
of the word in this industry.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
and the,
Eh,
I think they're looking,
can you get in terms of like winners and losers pushovers and people who get the
job done,
you know,
confident people versus people are not confident.
But I think you're correct.
And I think obviously humans operate on a giant spectrum and if you start going
around saying Alpha and Beta and that the idea that all alphas are the same or
all Betas are the same,
it's just as ridiculous as the idea of saying all the Democrats are the same.
Or is that Republicans,
it becomes an ideology.
Exactly.
Pro Male ideology.
At Cha,
I have the biggest problem with like over confident men's rights guys.
Yeah.
Cause I'm like,
listen,
we have all the rights.
Yeah.
Like
settled now.
Yeah.
We've got enough of them.
I had a whole bit about it.
I was like,
this is like divorce laws and that's it.
Everything else is stacked in our favor and just fucking chill out.
You're making us look bad.
Okay.